[Musica]
Buon pomeriggio
[Applauso]
Grazie
vedete un'immagine di San Francisco
perché la mia precedente relazione
stabile è stata con un uomo di San
Francisco proprio viveva lì c'è una roba
comoda era una relazione
intercontinentale quindi molto costosa
da portare avanti io intanto costosa in
tutti i sensi Eh certo mi riferisco ai
soldi ma anche costosa a livello emotivo
di sacrifici lavorativi sociali Però ne
valeva la pena Il punto è questo no cioè
quando ne vale la pena si fanno cose che
magari sulla carta non avremmo mai fatto
poi progressivamente non ci sono stati i
drammi liti anche per una questione di
mia personalità
progressivamente la relazione si è
svuotata dall'interno Come viene a
tantissime relazioni finché ho sentito
che non ne valeva più la pena ciò che
ottenevo dalla relazione non valeva le
risorse che io pagavo per stare nella
relazione che era diventata un cattivo
investimento emotivo una relazione che è
stata forte per lungo tempo stavamo
anche pensando di sposarci anche per
questioni di visto che però è rimasta
uccisa da un male silenzioso molto molto
comune che oggi chiamerò la sciatteria
su questo poi qui ci torniamo molto bene
come avete sentito dalla presentazione
Io sono anche un post purista che ora
non è esattamente un titolo accademico
però è un titolo è un ruolo molto serio
e la persona incaricata per una rivista
un portale di rispondere alla posta del
cuore che è una cosa un po' anni 80 ma
in realtà ancora ancora si sente nello
specifico Io lo faccio per un portale di
informazione lgbt Plus però Guardate
cioè i nostri drammi di uccelli in amore
Veramente sono trasversali a tutte le
persone a prescindere dalle
caratteristiche sessuali Comunque nelle
mie rubriche la peculiarità è che io un
approccio estremamente irrazionale
all'affettività c'è proprio ne parlo in
termini fiscali commerciali l'avete già
sentito nell'introduzione
Mi raccomando non c'è un modo giusto di
parlare d'amore ci sono preferenze
soggettive né si può parlare anche in
termini spirituali ma oggi non lo faremo
oggi ne parliamo in termini commerciali
però è Vi prego di notare che in ogni
slide ho messo una leggera sfumatura
rosa che se no poi mi dicono che sono
poco empatico Comunque nella mia è così
sensibile esperienza di posta corista se
vi dovesse dire oggi qual è secondo me
la principale causa di morte dei
rapporti umani in generale è nella sua
tetra semplicità Il darsi per scontati
atteggiamento che trovo ben riassunto
nel termine sciatteria la parola un po'
desueta quanto spesso la usate Ma che
per me descriverla da un atteggiamento
molto moderno con la sciatteria le cose
le si sta anche facendo ma senza darsi
degli standard
io poi purtroppo Temo che il darsi per
scontati dare per scontata l'altra
persona sia proprio la naturale
evoluzione purtroppo
all'acquisizione di una certezza
affettiva l'idea che se abbiamo un
rapporto di qualsiasi natura Vabbè andrà
avanti da solo in maniera spontanea Ecco
no
L'idea che l'altra persona ci sarà
sempre che poi ce lo diciamo proprio no
io per te ci sarò sempre cioè è molto
bello da dirsi però ho scoperto che
questa cosa non è da prendere alla
lettera cioè ci sono sempre in realtà
delle condizioni anche se non si
esplicitano per mancanza di
consapevolezza o diseducazione alla
comunicazione emotiva Infatti adesso
parliamo un attimo di questo per
evolvere dovremmo proprio capire
collettivamente molto bene la differenza
tra innamoramento e amore In realtà un
concetto semplice alla portata di
studenti delle scuole medie Ma loro non
viene dato
è un concetto che ha un impatto poi
enorme sulla qualità di vita delle
relazioni delle persone o perlomeno Ha
un impatto non inferiore a sapere che i
Mesopotamia vuol dire terra tra due
fiumi che credo venga insegnato tre
volte nel percorso scolastico
continuiamo a insegnare anche quello
però è quell'educazione affettiva magari
ce la infilerei ancora tanto si fanno
coincidere questi due concetti per dire
le commedie romantiche
Non raccontano storie d'amore sono
storie di cotte di innamoramenti che è
una cosa bellissima eh cioè
l'innamoramento ricambiato è una delle
emozioni più forti che si possano
provare però è una cosa diversa
dall'affetto poi stabile duraturo quei
film finiscono prima che inizi l'amore
il film Finisce quando i protagonisti
possono mettersi insieme risolti i
problemi che li tenevano distanti per
tenere in piedi la narrazione in
sostanza
oppure la storia della Sirenetta chi
rinuncia alla sua voce per stare con un
uomo con cui non ha neanche mai parlato
Non è una storia d'amore però è passata
alla storia come una storia d'amore Io
proprio la odio cioè È proprio l'emblema
ittico della dipendenza cioè
[Applauso]
è una persona che non riesce ad
apprezzare quello che ha ha un regno lo
svaluta idealizza solo quello che non ha
perché non riesce a provare gratitudine
è disposta a rinunciare alla sua
condizione di pesce senza provare
orgoglio per ciò che è per ottenere un
pesce di carne ora saprete che ci sono
state delle polemiche razziste
sull'opportunità di avere una sirenetta
nera motivate con una Non so come dire
premura nei confronti del rispetto
filologico della fiaba Danese Quando
l'unica differenza di sostanza con la
fiaba Danese e che alla fine la
Sirenetta muore Ecco bianca o nera non
ci interessa Io la voglio morta perché
rappresenta un tipo da una concezione di
amore dalla quale dovremmo evolverci
a me piace dire che l'innamoramento è
come un superalcolico di entrambe le
cose Infatti diciamo dalla testa Non
riesco a ragionare sono stordito è anche
bello eh ripeto mi raccomando non sto
minimizzando questa cosa
al contrario L'amore è come l'acqua
e trasparente
non sa di molto diciamolo però ti tiene
in vita lo bevi tutti i giorni e ti
tiene in vita per me questa metafora
piace molto perché sono anche
astemiobriaco anche col profumo quindi è
Perfetta Benissimo Allora questo serve
un tema che meriterebbe un intervento a
parte ma qui limitiamoci a dire che nel
passaggio dall'innamoramento le farfalle
nello stomaco a volte proprio cioè gli
avvoltoi nello stomaco lasciano spazio a
qualcosa di meno intenso ma molto più
duraturo sostenibile la fiducia per
evolvere prof dovremmo distinguere molto
bene tra fiducia di cui ho parlato E
sciatteria Ecco adesso siamo arrivati
alla al concetto che volevo condividere
per bene la differenza che secondo me
non è molto chiara persone di nuovo
Scusate se insisto ma per me è molto
importante perché non viene fatta
educazione su questi temi
facciamo degli esempi
di cose sottili dove A volte si confonde
appunto la fiducia con la batteria
fiducia e sapere che se commettiamo un
errore
una frase detta in un momento di rabbia
una scenata di gelosia l'altra persona
non troncherai istantaneamente il
rapporto ci darà la possibilità di
assumerci le nostre possibilità
di rimediare se non lo facesse avremmo
la sensazione di vivere con il terrore
di commettere un errore di camminare
proprio su una lastra di ghiaccio non
c'è fiducia se sentiamo questa cosa non
è un rapporto d'amore di fiducia
lasciateria invece è commettere un
errore e non darsi piena di indagare la
portata del danno causato pensando che
Vabbè se l'altra persona non si lamenta
troppo levavo il bene No ecco questo
modo di ragionare sciatto fiducia e non
vivere con apprensione il fisiologico
calo del desiderio sessuale in un
rapporto duraturo non pensare di dover
sempre impressionare con prestazione da
film porno Ogni tanto sì dai cioè quella
gradita però insomma non è assolutamente
un dovere ecco
sciatteria invece è smettere di
impegnarsi per creare ogni tanto una
situazione intima e soprattutto di
impegnarsi per tenere aperto il dialogo
sull'inevitabile evoluzione della
sessualità non sappiamo dove evolverà ma
sappiamo che evolverà Bisogna sforzarsi
di parlarne
fiducia
e non sentire il bisogno di dover
compiacere l'altra persona a 24 ore al
giorno con la paura che se le diciamo di
no una volta ci abbandona non c'è
fiducia se abbiamo questa questo timore
e sapere di poter dire a volte guarda
non ho voglia te puoi farlo da solo puoi
farlo con le tue amiche Io veramente
oggi proprio non ho voglia oppure dire
io so che in questo momento tu avresti
bisogno di questa cosa da me però non
riesco oggi non riesco a dartela io ti
prometto che appena sarò in condizioni
di farlo te la darò ma oggi non riesco
ci vuole fiducia per riuscire a dire
questo sciotteria e fare unicamente
quello che si vuole al grido di Eh ma io
sono fatto così
È un modo di dire sciatto proprio anche
quello senza cercare un compromesso con
i desideri bisogni la natura dell'altra
persona compromesso è un concetto che
secondo me ci piace sempre meno proprio
assorbiti dalla ricerca del partner
perfetto che secondo me è proprio
amplificata Fra l'altro dalle dinamiche
proprio delle App di Dating che ci danno
una percezione totalmente illusoria di
un bacino infinito di possibili partner
per cui è la prima cosa che non ci fa
impazzire diciamo Ah ok Ecco L'ennesimo
caso umano oppure gli facciamo una
diagnosi psichiatrica mancanza di
empatia narcisismo senza neanche averlo
conosciuto basta scartiamo troviamo una
persona invece che è perfetta Ecco la
persona giusta le persone giuste perché
non è che non è che sono un disegno per
cui c'è una persona nella vita si fanno
tanti percorsi magari ecco sono solo
persone le cui cose che ci piacciono
sono di più o pesano di più di quelle
che non ci piacciono fine
tutto il resto al lavoro e compromesso
altro esempio un tema Che so che molto
delicato questo fiducia è sapere che se
per fattori esogeni tipo lo stress gli
impegni o endogeni la salute fisica la
salute mentale il nostro corpo cambia
l'altra persona non ci abbandona ci
segue nel nostro percorso
sciatteria e rivelare che la cura per la
persona cioè tipo l'igiene personale
dettagli Nella presentazione non erano
standard che la persona aveva scelto per
se stessa che ai miei occhi conferiscono
sempre valore no Erano pubblicità
ingannevole per trovare un partner è
sciatto far capire che era veramente
tutto quello
e forse questo è l'esempio che che
preferisco in assoluto
fiducia
e smettere di nascondere i propri
problemi le proprie insicurezze di
vergognarsi te li faccio vedere questo
sono io sciatteria e non fare nulla per
gestire i propri problemi non ho detto
risolvere perché a volte sono dei
problemi che non si risolvono ce li
portiamo avanti tutta la vita si tratta
solo di conviverci in questi casi è
sufficiente vedere lo sforzo il
tentativo di integrarli un po' meglio la
consapevolezza in un rapporto d'amore di
fiducia ci si fa bastare Questo lo
sforzo che però ci deve essere di nuovo
quel semplicemente sono fatto così non
mi pongo il problema è sciatto e anzi mi
viene in mente un altro esempio allora
che voglio aggiungere perché a che fare
proprio quella comunicazione
fiducia e sentire di poter mettere dei
paletti cioè dire questa cosa a me non
va bene Mi dispiace Ok dei Confini non
perché l'altra persona piacciono a
nessuno piace Ovviamente ricevere
Insomma un limite Ma perché l'altra
persona li accetterà soprattutto no
rimanendo male eh Cioè è legittimo
rimanere male ma senza farci sentire in
colpa per perché abbiamo detto di no
sciatteria e non sforzarsi di comunicare
in maniera assertiva le nostre
preferenze le nostre esigenze cosa ci dà
fastidio delegando questo tipo di
comunicazione agli atteggiamenti passivo
aggressivi in cui l'altra persona deve
capire da sola perché se devo chiedere
non lo voglio più C'è chi ragiona così
eh però se l'aspettativa è questo di una
persona che ha a scatola chiusa capisca
ciò di cui abbiamo bisogno che ci si
metta con un astrologo un cartomante
anche queste persone avranno bisogno di
un abbraccio la sera dopo una giornata
passata a truffare la gente
però è questo
perché secondo me nessun rapporto Ah
nello specificato è questo Ma intendo
anche lavorativi amicali stiamo parlando
di relazioni romantiche però i rapporti
in generale perché nessun rapporto e mai
al sicuro da questo orrendo spettro
della sciatteria del darsi per scontati
per questa ragione
perché l'amore incondizionato tra adulti
non esiste anche se ce lo diciamo
l'amore è sempre condizionato a un certo
livello di
soddisfazione che cosa ho detto della
relazione precedente è quella di San
Francisco che era diventata un cattivo
investimento emotivo la mia
soddisfazione è calata è rimasta la
forma d'affetto ma non più sufficiente
portare avanti una relazione
ora l'idea del matrimonio ad esempio a
me piace ma non in termini romantico mi
vergognerei all'idea della cerimonia non
ho mi piace proprio l'idea di
contestualizzare il rapporto affettivo
in un frame giuridico contrattuale
Questo è un fetish mio Son d'accordo
ma il punto è che se anche se non ci si
sposa cosa assolutamente non necessaria
e prendere valida una relazione Comunque
il contratto c'è sempre anche se non ce
lo si dice perché non si è educati a
ragionare in questi termini C'è sempre
un contratto all'interno del quale due o
più persone per economia oggi Diciamo
due ma ci sono vari veramente modelli di
relazione comunque in cui queste persone
decidono di dare e ricevere stati e beni
emotivi stabiliscono un perimetro entro
il quale muoversi invecchiare insieme
può anche fare solo un pezzo di strada
assieme È un altro preconcetto è che una
relazione sia valida solo se si arriva
insieme Insomma fino fino alla vecchiaia
e fra l'altro le clausole di questo
contratto possono anche essere
aggiornate Perché le persone cambiano
evolvono da quando si sono incontrate ma
continuano ad esistere queste clausole
anche se non se ne si parla l'esistenza
di questo contratto il concetto è già
poco gradevole deriva da un concetto che
ancora peggio
ossia un adulto non ha il diritto di
essere amato questa ve la devo spiegare
bene
ragioniamola Al contrario
se esistesse questo diritto ciò
implicherebbe che gli altri abbiano il
tubi di amarlo voi volete il dovere di
amare qualcun altro che è interessato a
voi Voi volete il dovere di essere
sessualmente a tratti da qualcuno c'è
chi ragiona così eh C'è chi dice che se
voi non siete attratti da una persona
allora la state discriminando Il che
presupporrebbe l'esistenza del diritto
alle ricevere attrazione sessuale non
esiste questo diritto un adulto al
diritto ad essere rispettato e questa
sacro non ad essere desiderato a essere
amato e questa per me è una delle
ragioni per cui l'affettività è uno
degli ambiti proprio più stronzi della
nostra vita Chi è che non ha mai
sofferto proprio le pene dell'inferno
per l'amore eh per questa ragione perché
l'affettività è un bisogno dell'essere
umano considerato tutti gli effetti un
bisogno dell'essere umano ma al
contrario di bisogni legati al
sostentamento che richiedono l'accesso
alle risorse ma una volta che abbiamo
queste risorse il cibo non è che ci può
dire di no Se vogliamo mangiarlo una
persona può e se è quello che sente deve
dirci di no è il concetto di consenso il
che significa espulsi al rifiuto che è
una delle esperienze più dolorose della
vita perché noi non ce l'abbiamo questo
diritto abbiamo bisogno di affetto ma
gli altri non hanno il dovere di
soddisfarlo chi è che invece ha
effettivamente il diritto ad essere
amato un bambino o una bambina loro ce
l'hanno da parte dei loro genitori
caregiver di chi si prende cura di loro
purtroppo sappiamo che un diritto che
non sempre viene garantito ma loro ce
l'hanno per un adulto invece essere
amato è un privilegio ed è delicatissimo
da mantenere
concludo con una citazione di Battiato
che per me Spiega molto bene il concetto
l'apertura di una delle sue canzoni più
preferisco
rara la vita in due fatta di lievi gesti
e effetti di giornata
consistenti o no bisogna muoversi come
ospiti pieni di premure con delicata
attenzione questa visione per me è molto
lontana dall'idea che vorremmo avere di
un rapporto in cui Come dire ci togliamo
le scarpe è fatta Peccato che quella è
una concezione mortifera dal rapporto è
il vissero per sempre felice e contenti
Cioè non sappiamo di quanto si sono
impegnati per continuare a farlo
funzionare E invece no ospiti per me lo
siamo sempre perché io credo che la
solitudine sia proprio la condizione
esistenziale per eccellenza proprio
dell'essere umano perché noi possiamo
avere la famiglia più estesa la rete a
Michele più estesa Ma nella nostra testa
Siamo soli sono non c'entra nessuno
nella testa Siamo soli nella relazione
con gli altri siamo ospiti ospiti pieni
di premure e Qual è il contrario di
avere premura di un rapporto
la sciatteria trattarlo con sciatteria
lo posso dare per scontata l'altra
persona dare per scontato di possedere
il rapporto che sia lavorativo amicale o
romantico significa
condannarlo a morte
e ora Io capisco che magari questo come
dire non è il finale del discorso di
lieto fine che avreste voluto come
avviene alla fine della Sirenetta Che
palle però credo che sia il finale che
abbia bisogno di sentire ma anche qui Vi
prego di apprezzare che sotto al teschio
ho messo un cuoricino Rosa Perché
parlare di affettività ai termini
razionali non significa essere
insensibili Grazie
[Applauso]